au canada il exerce le comité sur la
situation des espèces en péril qui a
comme rôle de déterminer le statut
chacun des aspects si pour toutes les
espèces qui ont subi un déclin important
de la population comme c'est le cas pour
le martinet ramoneur et bien ils
établissent un classement comme pour le
martinet ramoneur on parle d'une espèce
qui étaient désignées menacées en raison
du déclin est par contre plus de
populations menacées
fictivement salle de sport pourrait
disparaître si la population continue à
diminuer de façon aussi maintenant et
quand on descend par le canada
mais la situation est un peu la main
mais je te jure canada on estime que la
population baisser d'environ 95% depuis
1968 en fait depuis qu'on a des des
données donc c'était une belle image à
rester jeune et la base c'est un peu
moins élevé mais quand même de l'ordre
de 58 % dont c'est aussi important
quatre
énormes c'est des chiffres fiables
c'est les meilleurs chiffres qu'on ne
sait quand même relativement fiable on
fait des inventaires d'oiseaux qu'on
appelle des relevés d'oiseaux nicheurs
c'est un peu partout en amérique du nord
c'est déjà les bénévoles juin qui font
les amateurs d'oiseaux le long des rues
et qui notent les espèces qui il était
et puis à la longue avec cette année
l'homme on peut refaire des statistiques
on s'aperçoit que dans les années fin
des années 60 68 il y avait plus de
manèges en or présentement les masses et
ramona s'alimente d'insectes et capture
ou comment on aperçoit désinfection
aérien sic aussi des hirondelles des
angles vendée moucherolle l'ensemble de
ces
espèces d'oiseaux locks nous reste est
capturé voile est en déclin même si pour
seulement visibles prudent nous donner
des scientifiques mais même les gens
nous avons souvent en avant je voulais
plus de rondelles que maintenant donc là
bas et c'est vraiment effrayant